we have first access this morning to
audio secretly recorded by one of the
police officers injured in the assault
on the capitol now this comes after a
meeting with Republican lawmakers after
the attack and it's being released ahead
of what could be the January 6
committee's last public hearing which is
scheduled for Thursday the officer in
question says what happened in that
meeting only added to his suffering
Scott McFarland has more
[Applause]
hailed as a hero on January 6th officer
Michael Fanon was beaten tased and
wounded trying to stop the rioters
now in connection to a new book by Fanon
CBS News has been given the first access
to a surreptitious audio recording he
made during a June 2021 meeting between
officers who responded January 6th and
house Republican leader Kevin McCarthy
who spoke about his actions at the
Capitol that day so I was trying to
convey to everybody
[Music]
um that's when I went on television too
the mother of Officer Brian sicknick who
died of natural causes a day after the
attack was also in the meeting and asked
McCarthy why then president Trump didn't
call off the mob do you know what was
going on you know they were fighting for
hours and hours and hours
you know I just uh
[Music]
in another exchange the known challenges
McCarthy when the Republican leader
urges against politicizing January 6th
[Music]
Kevin I agree with you the problem is it
is political because it happened here on
Capitol Hill and it involved a political
movement it involved a group of
extremist white right
[Music]
right wing uh element of our you know
American society which was mobilized by
politicians and that's just a fact in a
separate meeting with Republican senator
Lindsey Graham Fanon described the
assault officers faced and benone writes
Graham responded you guys should have
shot them all in the head we have much
work yet to do finone's Revelations come
as the house January 6 select committee
prepares to return to the spotlight this
week following a summer of behind the
scenes investigating and seeking more
records from the U.S Secret Service
about missing January 6th text messages
we've received a huge amount of
documents from the Secret Service and
have learned some additional things so
we plan to present what we found out
working through this summer I think it
will shed some light on the events of
the day and the events leading up to it
the house January 6 committee has just
weeks remaining to finish its work and
issue its final report neither
Congressman McCarthy nor Senator Graham
returned requests for comment from CBS
news about their conversations with
officer Fano Gail
all right Scott thank you very much
officer Michael Fanon will be here in
our studio in the next half hour so
we'll get a chance to ask him about
Senator Graham's comment that police
should have shot rioters in the head